welcome to this video yeah covering yet
another game from the European club cap
round round five of the tournament and
this is the third game that I played yes
the third game that applied here getting
confused to beat him and yeah the third
game and I had black and black again and
it was um in the in the match of my
budget team I nothing against chef under
belly in chest friends Berlin and so I
played a German play actually on Ward 5
it does a feeder master Christoph nobody
same same name sigh f just with a
slightly different spelling he's rated
2280 and with black I wanted to get up
to to play for wind be down but not
doing anything crazy I hardly do
anything crazy anyway so let's see what
happened in the prep I had seen that he
always plays this so I think I thought
that this is a welcome a chance to get
some things in that I have had analyzed
for my book project so it should be for
check and I saw that he always goes
Knight d2 interesting normal move more
common move as Bishop d 292 is not bad
however this this move has say certainly
ambitious y term if possible wants to
get the bishop am normally after my move
c5 um white goes a 3 which is the
ambitious way to play and in fact this
was also how he had played games before
I found some games in the database where
he played a 3 takes Queen takes this is
in a way the justification for blacks
for blacks play
it shouldn't be underestimated what
black is doing he is giving up his dark
squared Bishop giving wide the two
bishops and he was c5 he has weakened
the dark squares the compensation is the
didn't development black is getting a
pretty substantial eatin development
especially considering that quite often
wide fields obliged to take with the
Queen on default now or in the next
couple of moves for example after Knight
f3 be six wide very often would take
with the Queen as knight takes Bishop e7
as a bit embarrassing needs a player
three this is the the reason black is
very well developed and this means that
he has in a way compensation form for
giving up at the bishop here and
weakening the dark squares however in
our game he didn't do that he didn't
play three he played d takes d5 and this
i also had looked at in my prep briefly
but really really briefly as I
immediately had filed this under ok this
is harmless and if he does that I will
just play a game yeah in fact this is
what happened the next couple of moves
are are very very logical I took on c5
Bishop g2 castles Knight f3 96 castles
yeah here black has a fundamental choice
I can go b6 what I played v6 or also d5
this is in fact also a good move it is a
move more in the spirit of the Queens
gambit as it leads to a yeah Queens
gambit tirage it leads to an isolated
queen point position for example
something like that might happen
but this is a pretty decent iqp position
for black I have an active Bishop here
that gets some pressure going against f2
and why does not have much pressure on
the hive at the moment this is a decent
position I'm however i decided to go b6
for the simple reason that it is some
yada let's say slightly more complicated
which keeps more pieces on the board and
I'm not really a huge fan of those iqp
position so it's not i don't mind them
but i rather play this with all the
pieces on the board he played a 3 Bishop
to be seven and before yes this was
something that I definitely like to see
just from the perspective of getting a
complicated position if he instead if
you go back for a moment would have
played something like b3 Bishop b2 and
it feels very difficult would like to
initiate active play in the game
continuation it's not like okay I'm
getting huge activity this would be
wrong but here with a three before plate
I at least have a clear idea to attack
his Queen side and maybe get to a
situation where i get some some places
some good squares for my pieces we see
this pretty quickly this is very logical
and I went a five and this is what I was
talking about here he went b5 yeah I was
thinking that Bishop c3 is a decent
alternative by the way but he went b5
Bishop d3 yes I think about equal b5 and
look back at night back to be eight this
is what I was hoping for when he went
before this position is not it's not
better for black on
or something like that but what it
definitely is it is somewhat unbalanced
in a way there is a there is something
non-symmetrical in the position I have
this e5 square and I might get a night
to see five good spot on the other hand
white has gained some space on the
queenside and he sometimes has ideas if
we imagine a position with d6 being
played and the light squared Bishop
traded where he can get a knight to c6
so it is a position that is allowing
some some some constructive play where
you can even try something it's not like
you're not just sitting around 23 was
playing I was surprised by the smooth
but it's not not really bad and the
ideas to go Knight to g5 and yeah
threaten made on age 7 with Bishop f6
queen edge then made enter tech b7 so
it's a it's sort of a technical
technical type of idea may I wasn't I
wasn't really sure I mean it was pretty
clear to me that I can always play
something like d5 yeah something like
that to try to to simplify matters here
and probably draw the whole the whole
game but I wanted to do something I
didn't want to play play simplifying
moves so I went not d5 but I went
freaking back I went g6 yeah this keeps
pieces on the board and also it feels a
little bit we have it is this a little
bit of a provocation as this movie did
weakens the diagonal a bit but came in
white does not have anything they have a
I hope that he somehow fields provoked
to do something and yeah in fact i think
that the next couple of moves that he
plays that that they don't help really
um it is probably easiest now to just
play moves like Roxy one Ruby Dee one
yeah I'm something let's say this rookie
won a look-see 1d6 group d 1 Quincy's
have this type of position I think it it
should be about equal really I enjoy
this control 1 over C 5 but it's nothing
nothing great young probably about equal
and what he did is he got the same
structure but he lost time he played the
move if we go back to g6 he played Queen
to d4 which it didn't expect at all I
mean queen d for really you're wanting
to make me on g7 yeah that's not going
to happen and it's mostly loses time
this move I went to D 695 takes takes
ignite be to d7 yeah an interesting and
interesting position when to look the
one we are still talking about something
that it is said is rough roughly equal i
think the eruptive on the next movies is
interesting it might be a surprising to
some to some viewers here but it is a
fairly it's fairly fairly typical i
would say i went five now and i think
this is a good move it might look
strange to some people but it is a good
news why the point is that in this
position we have pawns on d6 n on c4
those phones aren't half open files the
question is which bonus is really as
really weaker I think that the c-4 porn
is the weaker porn
the structure I can attack it on the C
file well it's difficult for for white
to attack my d6 pawn d 5 wins the tempo
and very importantly it closes the
diagonal of the bishop white is
basically here settled with the bishop
on be too late stop doing very much it
looks at the well protected e5 pawn and
yeah it it's it's hard to to to find the
plan for white however he's not really
really worse in this position um what he
did now is and this is I think where it
counts 22 to getting getting him into
trouble he went through queen bee three
it's still okay it's not great but it's
it's still okay I went here and now now
I think he makes a mistake he plays the
move Queen c2 which I think miss places
miss places the Queen better is Queen f3
definitely Queen a free looks at those
critical light squares and maybe allows
a timely night jump to e4 one of the one
of the two nights after that it might
continue like that 2794 takes takes and
Queenie 6 this is what I was talking
about I'm attacking this pawn and while
my bed bed pawn on d6 is protected by
the bishop his bishop is not functioning
at all in this position it only looks at
very protective pawn on e5 while his
pawn is weak however there's nothing
nothing terrible happening what can take
and initiate a counter play yeah
something like that why it has a very
very substantial compensation for the
point it's even questionable if this is
a good idea for black being that
materialistic I have alternatives along
the way though for example I can instead
of Queen e6 if we go back instead of
Queen e6 I can also take on e4 and
now double against the pawn like this
yeah that's also interesting or also
this move might be enough might be an
option after the trade he has a hard
time to protect us it's a funny
positional situation i have a bad bishop
but i'm covering all my weaknesses well
c4 is not defensible um it's not that
clear where they can he can jettison
upon him and continued complicated stuff
but Queenie free if we go back tweener
free as what he should have done he went
not here he went to see to yeah now I
have Quincy 7 the problem is here his
nights now are on unlucky spots and he
does not have sufficient control anymore
over here for if you think about a move
like 94 now i set up this this very
awkward pen so that means he'd lost us
loose control over the e4 square he went
Roxy one I gave the check to went back
with the king yeah and now we see that I
control the e4 square which is a very
nice nice thing to do my further plan is
simple I was started with Roxy 7 what
I'm doing with Roxy 7s playing this
little candidus little annoying
improvement means that passes the right
to move too wide and ask right okay okay
you're the one with the weakness on c4
what are you doing it's not that easy to
play this position um but still of
course why it is not in any huge trouble
what he probably should have done is
something like a four you're intending
the bishop placing the bishop on a 3-2
exchange it or get some play against the
six after that I think it's still okay
for
for wide I can I can do something like
that for example something like that or
instead of h6 I also could have thought
about about other options I think
probably rook c8 also comes into
consideration it's a very complicated
position I would have liked like yeah
but it's nothing nothing super great
however hear something surprising
happened my opponent already in slide
time pressure and he didn't really like
the position it was very visible that he
felt uncomfortable um he went for the
most f3 yeah and this is a really a
first-class a first-class blunder um
surprising surprising blunder because um
the answer is is very obvious actually I
didn't take long and just when 94 and
this is a really a big problem now yeah
the bishop is attacking the night and
I'm threatening this jump with a huge
huge fork and this is really really
really really really bad for white if we
look at this if he takes g4 I grab here
and now we see that this Bishop all of a
song is turning into a fantastic piece
here yeah I'm threatening Bishop e3 all
of a sudden and also from a positional
point of view I'm threatening to take on
d too yeah let's say you plays rook f3
to cover the check on you three black
and just take it and place the knight on
e4 and this is just the dream yeah the
night only four is on a light square he
has no peace anymore that can contest
this night and I still have the pressure
against you for now therefore night is
also covering my weakness so a fantastic
position or something like this let's
say and rook c8 and white has a hard
time to keep his position
together fantastic yeah so this he
really needed to avoid at all costs so
he decided to not take but to drop back
which is basically giving up the
exchange but this is still better than
the other position were just really
really losing on I went to e3 and he
took on c5 yeah here I saw am way too
yeah to do to change the position but
but in my favor I took with 25 and he
went Queen d3 and here's an important
moment probably queen e form was wasn't
more interesting try because of one
thing yeah of course my my queen obese
happiness is hanging so I cannot take
everyone but it is very important to
notice if I take and he takes that in
this position here I definitely should
not take on c4 Luke takes before at
first looks like it's it's like
instantly winning the rook hanging on
everyone if Y takes Knight takes and
winning a b2 hangs d5 is carrying a
terrible position but in this position
he has the fantastic move King f2 at all
of a sudden this isn't great it's really
funny yep like black he really has no
great news so it's a very very weird
situation it is much better instead of
taking on c4 to just drop the rook back
and this again is clearly better for
black yeah I'm attacking the rook and
attacking see form so i will win
material he went not here he went to d3
yeah and here i just took took a look
why not it's it's a it's an exchange and
and should win the game definite
he went to reform night XD for ya and
here yeah I wasn't totally I wasn't
totally sure what's best but I actually
like my solution to be honest at the
moment I morooka even but ok the
exchanges hey man I distract and I saw a
way to to get to change the position but
in a way that hugely favors me and the
the materialistic solution was just to
retreat here yeah like this yeah here
here and and Quincy 8 intending to take
and widest widest bastard here Renee I
can do that as well but I think my
solution is also nice after this 94 I
took on not here I took on g3 as a
desperado just taking a pawn here we
captured with the pawn what else and now
I went d5 and this is just a good
transformation it attacks the night and
basically forces the night to take after
cd5 route 25 yeah I'm exchanged pawn up
everything up so he needs to take so I
return the exchange I take with a check
very important he moves the king and now
the move deform this is what I had
calculated when I was giving away giving
back the exchange and once I once i saw
this position I pretty quickly went for
it because it is a very clean solution
to win the game black now is a pawn up I
have the space advantage and extra porn
in the center and the better Bishop and
I have a clear plan of attack f-5e for
and this steamroller should win the game
yeah in fact this is what happened ruga
h1 f5
Bishop c1e for white really has nowhere
no way to defend the position you can
argue that I didn't didn't play the best
possible way but it always kept a
winning edge rook to eight and ten
degree 3 attacked the rook I went up
Queenie one yeah this felt slightly
annoying didn't want a piece coming in
to f6 ya like like like this it's
probably still winning but I didn't want
that so I covered instead of this i
covered the sixth-ranked he went to ruby
one Queen d7 still preparing d3 Bishop
f4 Ruby 6 King f1 yeah and around here i
was thinking okay there should be some
direct win so i pushed pushed III and he
took on me for yeah this was maybe more
a bit more tenacious one point being
that the move Bishop deform is answered
by this quite quite embarrassing so I
wouldn't have done that but I can take
here intending rookie to after deform
Bishop d6 black is also winning I'm just
invading here with a decisive attack
still maybe it was a bit a bit tougher
he took not here what only for ya now I
made a mistake definitely um it was
easier now to just recapture only for
because I'm opening up this diagonal
immediately for my queen intending to
move the rook and queen h3 this was was
the and what's the easiest solution I
took on e2 takes rook takes king of one
because others thought okay there must
be a win right there must be a win it is
winning but the the other continuation
was simpler Queenie 6 and rook t5 until
all of a sudden it turned out whom maybe
this isn't so easy but then
found a way that wins it seems that
there's more than one way but i found
one way that that does the trick I went
g5 rukia to also seems to win g5 he went
here yeah the more interesting moves was
the capture of course then c4 was mad
the intended Queen a tree made that can
only be answered by g4 note that if he
gives the check I just go here and
that's it he does not have a follow-up
check it's very important and I'm
threatening this mate and also on c4
once the rook leaves d5 there is this
dual threat yeah he only has G for this
was the line and now black can play
simply every yeah intending rookie true
and I didn't find anything remotely
playable for white I think that this was
a pretty convincing way to do it and he
still he cannot move the rook that's
very important if he moves the rook
somewhere like here I do this and it's
made yeah so then even a check is just a
check after that I'm threatening
checkmate on c4 and he has no no check
no temple moved to continue the whole
thing so this is what I was calculating
and fortunately I was right with this
after g5 he however went Bishop to c7
and this is maybe even somewhat easy and
now I have Queen h6 intending Queen edge
one mate oops or queen the age three
mates for that matter both both are made
give the check and check when two is six
and that's it there are no meaningful
checks I can take the pieces easily that
can give a check on e5 or do six or
seven so he has no way to prevent Queen
edge one mate or queen 83 may
yeah so this was the second win in this
tournament that has scored again with
black um yeah i was i was quite quite
satisfied with the game it took me about
two to finish this off I mean this
calculation with g5 took me awhile and I
would have liked to see this a bit
quicker but okay a win is a win is a win
and if you check it with them with the
engine um it does not really improve on
it very much it always gives me a
winning edge so yeah I was I was I was
satisfied with this if we recap the
whole thing quickly we got an
interesting structure from the opening
and I think this is the kind of
structure that is very welcome if you
want to play for when it's not
symmetrical and there is some tension in
it yeah it turned out that he made some
small inaccuracies with this Queen man
was he lost some time like this with
Queen d3 yeah this is really losing time
and I got control over the importantly
foursquare here of course he helped me
enormously by going f3 yeah if he does
not do that it's a entirely entirely
different thing um it's um by the way um
I think the move like books his
happiness may be something that is
sometimes not appreciated by people it's
not like a super strong move I'm not
saying that but sometimes it's better to
do those little improving moves and and
did not play so forcing like h6 for
example pushing the night back which
would not be really bad but it makes
life easy for white in a way he goes to
a free and that's it after Luke c7 you
really asked right okay what are you
doing find a move and I'm not saying
that attempted him he took playing f3
but if I would have forced age 69 f3 it
wouldn't have happened it's just
sometimes good to just let say yeah let
him think
the move plan and just not play that
that forcing chess okay i hope you
enjoyed the coverage for this game
thanks for watching